imagine that there are people living in
the cave
deep underground the cave has a mouth
that opens to the light above
and a passage exists from this all the
way down to the people
they have lived there as captives from
infancy
with their legs and necks bound in
chains
they cannot move all they can do is
stare directly forward
as the chains stop them from turning
their heads around
imagine that far above and behind them
blazes a great fire
behind this fire and the captives a low
wall
is erected along a path something like
puppeteers use
to hide themselves during their shows
look and you will also see other people
carrying
objects back and forth along the wall
things of every kind statues and other
carvings made of stone or
wood and many other artifacts that
people have made
some of these other people speak while
others remain silent
it's a bizarre situation and a bizarre
group of captives
from the beginning the captives have
never managed whether on their own or
with the help of others to see anything
besides the shadows that are continually
projected on the wall
in front of them by the glow of the fire
now if they could speak
would you say that these captives would
imagine that the names they give to the
things they were able to see
applied to real things it would have to
be so
and if a sound reverberated through
their cave
from one of the other people passing
behind the wall do you suppose
that the captives would think anything
but the passing shadow
was what really made the sound i guess
not
then undoubtedly such captives would
consider the truth to be nothing but the
shadows of the moving objects and their
sounds
now look again and think about what
would happen if they were released from
these chains and these
misconceptions imagine one of them is
set free from his shackles
and immediately made to stand up and
turn his head around
to take steps to gaze up toward the fire
and all of this was painful
and the glare from the light made him
unable to see the objects that cast the
shadows
what do you think his reaction would be
if someone informed him that
everything he had formerly known was
illusion and delusion
but that now he was a few steps closer
to reality
oriented now toward things that were
more authentic
and he was able to see more truly now
let's say that he's forcibly dragged
up the steep climb out of the cave and
started climbing
until finally he stands in the light in
front of the sun
under that light wouldn't his eyes be
nearly blinded
unable to discern any of those things
that we ourselves call real
it would take time i suppose for him to
get used to seeing reality as it is
in the beginning he might only trace the
shadows of the outside world
then reflections of people and other
things in the water
next he would come to see the actual
form of things themselves
then he would behold the celestial
objects and the sky itself
especially by night seeing the light of
the stars and the moon with
greater ease than the sun and its light
by day and at some point i think
he would at last be able to gaze upon
the sun itself
neither as reflected in water nor as a
shadow in some other place
but in its own place as it really
released
and now he will begin to reason he will
find that the sun
is the source for the seasons and the
years and governor of every visible
thing
and is ultimately the origin of
everything previously known so to speak
in that case shouldn't he remember his
fellow prisoners and their
original dwelling and what was accepted
as wisdom in that setting
don't you imagine he would consider
himself fortunate for this
transformation
and feel pity for the captives if such a
man would go back to his original place
inside the cave
wouldn't his eyes be filled with
darkness coming back from the sun
wouldn't his eyes still be adjusting to
the darkness and it may take a while
before
they can see the shadows again wouldn't
he become a laughing stock for the other
captives
wouldn't they say you have returned from
your adventure up there with ruined eyes
would they not say that the ascent was a
waste of time
and if you attempted to free them and
push them to escape the cave
don't you think that they might even try
to kill him for this
this allegory attempts to compare the
visible world to the underground cave
and the captives ascend to be the ascent
of the soul to the intellectual world
regardless it appears to me that in the
world of knowledge
the idea of good appears last of all
and it is perceived with great
difficulty but when it is seen
it leads us directly to the finding of
the universal cause
of all that is right and beautiful it is
the source of visible light
and in the intellectual world it is the
master of truth and reason
and whoever in private or in public
would behave in a sensible way we have
his eyes fixed on this idea
we should not be surprised that
individuals who have reached this level
of understanding
might be unwilling to spend their time
on mundane affairs
for their souls would always feel a
calling for the higher things
the ability and means of learning is
already present in the soul
as the eye could not turn from darkness
to light unless the whole body moved
so it is that the mind can only turn
around from the world of becoming to
that of being
by a movement of the whole soul the soul
must learn
degree by degree by slowly turning
towards the light
to endure the contemplation of being and
of the brightest and the best of being
or
in other words of what we consider as
the greater
good hey guys
so hope you enjoyed this visual
representation of the allegory of the k
which is a short story that can be found
in the book republic by plato
ah this is an abridged version of a
translation i found online
i tried to change it a bit so that it
has a better flow
because the original text even in greek
sometimes sounds weird
but that's normal because in every epoch
people speak in different ways so for me
the allegory of the cave is an
incredible philosophical text because of
the
symbolisms that illuminate so many
powerful ideas
obviously the text can be interpreted in
many ways but i will offer
the overarching idea the prisoners
represent all of us
all individuals who are trapped in a
kind of prosaic
simplistic and just sensory
interpretation of the world the
puppeteers could represent all these
people or institutions that attempt to
impose certain narratives upon us
the chains allude to all those things
that keep us shackled in a very
limited intellectual and perceptual
understanding of the world around us
the cave obviously is this limited world
that keeps us
trapped and the shadows are the only
things we perceive as real because of
all the limitations that we have so
at some point one prisoner somehow
escapes the cave and gains access to the
outer world
which symbolizes the absolute truth so
to speak
which is kind of abstract but in short
one can define this truth as
the truth disengage from illusions
delusions propaganda lies
and uh different absurdities plato makes
three important points
in this allegory with regards to the
truth
number one that it takes time to get
accustomed to the truth and eventually
re-engineer one's perception in order to
understand it and
accept it number two that once one sees
the truth and
accepts it one can never go back to
their former state
and number three that the truth can be
perceived as something dangerous by some
people
because often the truth hurts so much
that people will feel that
it's not worth risking what they have
for something so
precarious undoubtedly this is an
incredible text that
echoes many visceral ideas that have
troubled us
throughout the history of mankind i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did as always please make sure to
like subscribe
get notifications and leave a comment
and please if you feel like
support the channel uh your support
means the world to me and i try to
upload
really high quality videos that are very
difficult to find elsewhere on
youtube there are many ways to do so
please check all the available options
in the description below
again thanks for watching see you soon
adrian out
[Music]